ايضا موقف اخر تحميل
لانتقاد للموقف الامريكي وفي تجاهل هواجس
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين قد نتحدث
عنه بعد قليل لكن دعنا نذهب الى ايران هل
تعتقد انه من الممكن التفاهم حاليا مع هذا
النظام الايراني
النظام الايراني الراهن كما نراه مزعزع
جدا بسبب المظاهرات المستمره منذ شهور
والتي
يقودها جيل جديد واعتقد ان هنا ايضا هناك
انتقال للاجيال وهو امر يجب اخذه في
الحسبان بشكل عام رغبه فرنسا دائما وابدا
كانت القول ان ايران موجوده هي موجوده في
المنطقه ويجب ان يكون لديها مكان او مكان
يمكن ان يتم التشاور بشانه مع الدول
المجاوره نحن كنا مهتمين بان ايران عبر
ربما وساطات او او
مثل حزب الله والحوثيين يحاولوا اتموقع في
مناطق اخرى لحمايه نفسه وكذلك زعزعه بلدان
الاقليم هذا امر غير مقبول
وعملنا
مرارا بان يند الايرانيون في المجتمع
الدولي واكدوا على ذلك ولكن ربما يحتاجون
لمكانهم المناسب
ومع مراعاه بان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه تريد
ان تتمدد وهذا ايضا عنصر يجب اخذه في
موازين القوه التي نريدها ولكن الفكره هي
ان يتم تجنب وكان هذا هو هدف
الاتفاق النووي الذي للاسف انسحب منه
الامريكيون اذا الهدف هو منح ايران
مكاننا او مكانتها
وان تبقى ايران عند مستوى معين في المجال
النووي ان تستفيد من الاستثمارات ثم تندمج
في المجتمع الدولي الرئيس ترامب والامريكي
انتقدوا موقف معاكس وبالتالي لا يمكن
اصلاح كوثر وبالتالي ايران موجوده اليوم
وهي طبعا
داخلي لا نعلم كيف ستتطور الامور لكن
الاكيد هو ان ايران من خلال بعض التصرفات
تعرض للخطر الاستقرار في عدد من البلدان
في المنطقه هذه المنطقه التي هي بحاجه
للاستقرار وما يهم هو ان تحل هذه المنطقه
مشكلتها بنفسها مع دعم بطلب من هذه
البلدان بدعم من البلدان الاجنبيه فرنسا
الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
مستعدون لدعم هذه المنطقه لتحقيق
الاستقرار لان ذلك في مصلحه الجميع
فالاستقرار مهم لتنميه الشعوب وازدهارها
هذا هو الوضع هو غير مستقر وقد يظل كذلك
لفتره من الزمن